[Applause]
getting in trouble
with the law at an early age can lead to
a lifetime of consequences for kids
my next guest is looking to change all
that in seattle with an innovative
program
that gives kids an alternative instead
of being prosecuted they can choose to
see the best in themselves
and thrive take a look choose 180 is a
non-profit organization
our foremost goal is to transform
systems of injustice to no longer do
harm
to communities particularly the black
and brown community so tell me about a
time
that you made that different decision
the difference between a young person
who's successful
and a young person who has challenges
has everything to do with the community
surrounding them
what the program aims to do is to not
label a kid for a mistake
it seeks to help a kid make better
decisions
it doesn't always have to be a jail cell
or a judge or a courtroom
last year we supported a little over 500
youth and young adults
over 90 percent of them don't return to
the criminal legal system within 12
months of participating in our program
which means that community is better
because a young person is better because
that family is better
[Music]
this is the greatest organization i'm so
excited y'all over the years
sean good the executive director of
choose 180 has helped more than
6 000 kids turn their lives around
he's what we like to call a rad human
[Music]
please welcome sean everybody
what's up man how you doing i am amazing
kelly
um well meet jessie hi nice to meet you
hey jessie
hi great to meet you as well you too
well we were just talking in the break
how excited we are like she does this
podcast she gets to meet people that are
really cool and changing people's lives
and have
have a lot of information that we maybe
don't know about and i have been
so excited since reading all about you
about having you on the show i think
it's incredible what you're doing
um so two very different events in your
childhood
inspired what you do right now right
yeah absolutely you know when
when i was six years old i visited my
brother
who at the age of 13 was incarcerated
for
a poor choice that he made and he was
locked up inside of
a kid jail until he was a 21 year old
man
and when i went to visit him on this day
the uh the security guard
when i stepped into the building pointed
me to an article that was on the wall
behind me and this article
was all about my brother and how he did
this amazing job going and visiting a
school and inspiring the young people
and it wasn't lost on me at the age of
six that although he could do so much
great outside of this building
because of a poor choice he made when he
was a 13 year old he was stuck in here
until he was 21
and by the time i got to the age of
about 10 11 12
i had a really difficult anger
management problems and i would
break holes in doors and walls and even
harm my mother and the police got called
on me
and i remember this day clearly when the
police brought me down put me in the
back of their car
and said look we can take you with us or
send you back upstairs
but if we send you back upstairs and we
have to come back
you're definitely coming with us again
and that moment of grace
was a big pivot moment for me that
helped me commit to a new direction for
my life
wow and that's quite a moment too
because you never know
you know what the kid will choose you
know and it's it's a it's an interesting
thing though that you've you've pointed
out that
they can choose the positive path and i
think that's the coolest part of what
you're doing
um the kids in choose 180 just have to
do a one-day program to get their
charges dropped right so how does it
work
we have this really unique relationship
with the district attorneys in our
community
where we're able to give young people
community instead of a courtroom and
essentially what happens is when a young
person's behavior is criminalized
they get referred to our program instead
of referred to the court system they
show up to the shared space with people
with lived experience that mirrors them
they hear testimonies from folks through
this exercise we have called the color
of connectedness where
i'll tell my story for example about how
i used to damage property that wasn't
mine and then
i will invite the young people their
connected adults the prosecutors in the
space the staff the volunteers so i'll
come down and get like a green mardi
gras bead
and we'll do the same thing for physical
violence for theft and drugs and alcohol
and before you know it everybody in the
space has these beads around their neck
and the young people recognize that i'm
not here because i'm guilty because if
that's the case then all of us are
guilty then it must be for something
different it's for grace and we've
recognized that grace is a far better
motivator for behavior change than guilt
ever could be
absolutely um did you feel like you had
moments in your life that you're like
oh god i'm glad that i'm glad that my
whole path wasn't decided because of
that one thing like
one mistake yeah i mean what you're
saying it really it reminds me of this
thing that i
i try to recognize which is that like
there are there's angels everywhere and
so
my story is um when i was a little kid i
didn't really like school that much but
i knew i wanted to be an actor
and my parents sent me to this acting
program over the summer
and then the following semester we
hadn't enrolled because my family was
tight on money and we just couldn't
afford to swing it
and the director of the program called
my parents like hey we noticed that um
jesse isn't signed up for this next
semester just trying to
you know make sure that you're all good
to go like it's starting soon
and my mom explained oh you know we're a
little tight right now so we're gonna
we're gonna take a little time off
and this director of the program she
said um well you know jessie's really
intense
in class and she gets the other kids to
focus so
we want to offer her a lifetime
scholarship and she can come whenever
she wants
and so i got to go to acting classes for
10 years because of this woman ellen
spindell and it was like wow
totally blessed by an angel kind of
moment i'm so grateful to her you know
it's so funny i had similar moments in
my life we had no money
there wasn't a lot of support in that
area because there just couldn't be yeah
and i had people help me
and i think what you're saying is if you
give kids that maybe don't have the
opportunity because of finances that
don't have
the opportunity because of they don't
have that support system those little
moments
look at where we are right now we would
probably not be here
had people not believed in us and had
they not you know
kind of helped us on a better path and
and one that would had opportunity
a few years ago our next guest was
homeless and facing serious jail time
that's when she discovered choose 180
and made a commitment to change
now her life looks drastically different
everybody say hello to lamaria
[Applause]
hi say hi to jesse as well
hi jessie all right well lamaria can you
tell us a little about your background
first
um you know i grew up and i was
bullied you know being a bigger girl my
mom wasn't financially stable to give me
the things that could
um distract bullies from believing me
um so at about 13 my behavior changed
and i began stealing
i didn't enter the the criminal justice
system until i was 18 for theft
um and when i went to jail i got out i
got out to being homeless kelly
i got out to couch surfing
um you know and i was entering into
survival mode
how can i survive and that led to
cashing bad checks
and cash and bag checks led to facing
seven
felony forges so
you can only imagine you know how that
was i think that's the interesting thing
about situations like this is everybody
thinks they're invincible you're not
you don't have any idea like what could
your place could burn down everything
could go up and play
and all of a sudden you're in a
completely different environment or you
don't have the supports
around you you don't have people to call
for money like not everybody has that
and that can happen to anyone well what
was your experience like with the
program
oh my experience was amazing kelly um
you know like i said earlier i was
homeless um i was
in a place where i didn't know if i
could stop stealing i didn't know if i
could
stop cashing checks um and i came into
the program i walked into the workshop
thinking it's going to be a one day
thing
but it turned into two years and a half
of turning my life around
building amazing relationships and um i
in that in the midst of that time
i um got stable um i learned life
lessons
um how to financially save how to
be stable within a home they paid for
all my moving costs
um just just a new start for me um
it was amazing honestly um truthfully
and
in the midst of that as well um all
seven forgery charges kelly are gone
i did not have to go to jail there were
so many community leaders that
on my behalf wrote a letter that you
know la maria
you know was in the circumstances to
survive and that's not her
she can do better um and that resulted
to
employment sean just offered me um
employment
to give back to my community to to help
out youth
young girls just like me so i that's my
calling
and i just want to be the best at that i
love it you want to be the best version
of yourself and that's what i love from
the video too that we played before we
we brought sean out
is you know he said this isn't just a
good thing for these individuals it's an
amazing thing for these individuals but
it's an even bigger thing and a bigger
impact on the community as a whole
um lamaria i understand that you you
have something you want to say to sean
right
yes i do um uncle sean i just wanted to
let you know
thank you for everything you've done for
me thank you for everything you do for
the seattle community
um i love you forever for it and i
appreciate all the opportunities and i
can't wait to see what the future holds
and we love what choose 180 is all about
and how it's changing lives um so sean
we are giving the program ten thousand
dollars how's that sound
what oh that sounds amazing that was
great
all right we love what you're doing and
i i've been so excited literally to have
you on this show
and i'm i'm it's just such a gift you're
such a gift and
and you should let those tears flow man
that means it matters it's okay
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever